We're asked to evaluate
the expression a squared
plus 10b minus 8 when a is
equal to 7 and b is equal to 4.
So to evaluate the
expression, we really just
have to substitute a with 7 and
substitute b with negative 4
because they're saying evaluate
it when a is equal to 7
and b is equal to negative 4.
So let's do that.
So a everywhere we see
an a in the expression,
we should put a 7 there.
So instead of a squared, we
should write 7 squared plus--
I'll do it in that same
color-- plus 10 times b.
But instead of a b
there, we are now
going to substitute it with
b is equal to negative 4.
So 10 times negative 4 instead
of the b right over there.
And then we have the minus 8.
And now we just have
to evaluate this thing.
7 squared is 49.
And then 10 times negative 4.
Remember, order of
operations, multiplication
comes before addition.
So we have to multiply this.
10 times negative
4 is negative 40.
So it's negative 40.
And then we have minus
8 back over here.
And so we get 49
plus negative 40,
which is really the same
thing as 49 minus 40
is going to be 9.
And then we're going to
subtract 8 from that.
And so we get 1.
49 minus 40 is 9 minus 8 is 1.
And we are done.
We've evaluated the expression
when a is equal to 7
and b is equal to negative 4.